new details this afternoon on that huge
construction site fire in the southwest
Valley Clark County now says the fire
department plans to have Crews work
four-hour shifts on a rotation to keep
an eye on the Flames the fire actually
flared up again early this morning
here's a live look at the site right now
and it is basically all just smoke and
dust there now the construction sites
relatively remote so Clark County Fire
is just going to let the building burn
in a relatively controlled manner local
state and federal investigators are now
looking for a cause now this was
supposed to be the cactus apartments
near 215 in Buffalo the developer says
it was a 90 million dollar project it
involves more than 600 new homes and
retail space we understand it was 75
percent complete when the fire started